good morning it's seven o'clock you're
watching the only breakfast show live
from westminster after weeks of
deliberation
the eu has for now stopped short of
imposing export curves on vaccine doses
as it attempts to remedy its slow moving
rollout
this morning we'll ask what last night's
virtual eu council meeting
means for the uk and whether it's the
win-win outcome that was aimed for
also this morning the world war ii
veteran who's completing a lockdown
cycle challenge as he celebrates his
100th birthday
from now i shan't touch them instead
i'll keep my hands a little way above
them the whole time
watch this at quarter to ten we'll be
finding out if online magic
shows can do the trick it's friday the
26th of march
the eu warns astrazeneca to fulfill its
vaccine contracts with europe
as the commission president claims she's
seen no deliveries arrive
from the uk i have no knowledge so far
of uk exports perhaps i'm mistaken and
waiting for that transparency
hitting back china sanctions more than a
dozen individuals and organizations in
the uk
after britain took similar action over
concerns about human rights abuses
the nspcc says platforms owned by
facebook are being used in more than
half of
online child sex crimes
grounded the raf pauses flights of hawk
t1 jets
after a crash in cornwall which left two
pilots in hospital
a message to take to the oscars we speak
to kerry mulligan and director emma
fennel
on their film tackling predatory
behaviour towards women
and it's turning briefly cold over the
next 24 hours with wintry showers for
some i'll have details for you later in
the programme
good morning the eu has warned
astrazeneca it must fulfill its
contracts with europe before sending
vaccines elsewhere
but officials stopped short of
immediately introducing export
restrictions
the eu had touted imposing export curbs
on vaccines
with a continence vaccination program
lagging behind the uk's
instead european commission president us
lavon de lane
ordered astrazeneca to catch up with
orders its promise to europe
she also called for transparency from
other countries
saying she had no knowledge of the uk
exporting doses to the block
from brussels our europe correspondent
michelle clifford reports
the residents of brussels were probably
glad it was a virtual summit this time
round
there was none of the usual traffic
chaos and congestion when eu leaders
descend
the lunchtime customers seeking out some
of the city's famous fries
were all too aware their prime minister
and others were busy talking
and about what vaccines or rather a lack
of them
and what to do to get more
i hope it's going to arrive um sooner
and uh that we're going to get
vaccinated soon it should be a
worldwide uh agreement so that everybody
has the same change to be vaccined
we have several times astrazeneca and
and
and fiverr who who said yeah we cannot
deliver
to europe uh because we don't have
any more nearby a long queue for
vaccinations which have been rolled out
more slowly than people would have
liked and much more slowly than across
the channel
the uk success of inoculating citizens
as well known here
and around the eu and will have focused
the minds of leaders as they met
remotely to discuss kovid and agreed to
tightening vaccine export rules
we want to make sure that europe gets
its fair
share of vaccines because we must be
able to explain
to our citizens that if companies
export their vaccines to the whole world
it is because they are fully honoring
their commitments
and it does not risk security of supply
in the european union
days of tension have been growing
between the eu and uk over the issue of
exports
the european commission saying millions
of doses have been sent across the
channel
with no vaccines coming in the other
direction i have no knowledge so far
of uk exports perhaps i'm mistaken and
waiting for that transparency
and the same goes for many other regions
in the world
leaders agreed to step up production of
vaccines and improve
rollout and were joined for a time by
u.s president joe biden
who has his own covered difficulties at
home
and whilst there has been eu uk acrimony
the two sides have agreed to try to work
together
to expand supplies for all citizens that
didn't stop france's president
taking a swipe at some on the uk side
not politicians
but the press
europe is not a selfish continent i
think it's important because when i read
the press across the channel
they say that it's the eu being selfish
this is false
a note of positivity but who knows how
long it will last if
export issues ultimately interrupt the
vaccine program beyond eu shores
michelle clifford sky news brussels
well aleister bunkel is in brussels for
us now
and um ali does this now mean that the
uk vaccine rollout program will be
unaffected
no i think it's far too early to uh have
any kind of definitive conclusion about
what it means for the uk
and and indeed for the eu i mean what i
would say in
positive terms aside from that sort of
one slightly snarky remark from ursula
von de loin that michelle had in her
report there about waiting to see
figures from the uk on the whole the
language was
more directed at astrazeneca as the
vaccine manufacturer
rather than the united kingdom so i
think talks continue between the uk
and the eu to see how they can achieve
their
so-called win-win situation something i
think most people think is probably
impossible but not just that
dispute actually the eu arguably has
greater trouble on its hands
internally there is real disgruntlement
between a lot of states they are not
getting their fair share
of the vaccine from within particularly
austria
the austrian premier uh sebastian kurtz
really annoying quite a lot of his
fellow leaders during the video
conference video summit yesterday
by saying that austria should be on the
priority list something that angela
merkel completely disagrees with
so not only is the eu fighting to secure
more vaccines it also has a fight within
as to how those vaccines are distributed
alistar thank you
for well housing secretary robert
generic joins me now good morning to you
so the eu stops short
of an export ban to the uk can you
therefore assure people
that they will get their vaccinations on
time in this country
yes i can we are on course to meet both
of our targets that
all the over 50s and those with clinical
vulnerabilities
will be vaccinated or at least with
their first jab by the middle of april
and that all adults will get their
vaccination
by the end of july we've got line of
sight we know we've got the supplies
ahead to deliver on those two critical
targets
but look we are continuing to talk to
our partners
in the european union none of us want to
see
any harm to international supply chains
we've got to work together
and cooperate to ensure that we can get
the vaccine
and we can have a win-win situation for
both the uk
and the european union ursula vonderlion
says she hasn't seen any vaccines
exported from
the uk have we exported any vaccines
well vaccines are based on complex
international supply chains
there are elements of the vaccines being
produced in the uk there are elements
being produced in parts of the european
union
and indeed all over the world we're
working with the serum institute for
example
uh in india so it is a critical
for all countries that there are free
flow of medical products including
vaccines across
international borders and it would be
very damaging if
countries started to pull up drawbridges
and prevent
vaccines medicines or elements of them
crossing
international borders and the uk
strongly strongly
opposes that would the uk ever consider
blocking vaccines to the eu though if
they decided to
have an export ban well i'm not going to
get into
that kind of talk i think that's
unhelpful we will continue to discuss
the situation with the european union to
encourage them
to stick to the very clear commitments
that they gave
just a few weeks ago which were that
existing contractual
obligations will be honored that
vaccines and
other medicines can cross borders
unhindered
that's absolutely critical and of course
we'll continue working
with the fantastic manufacturers like
astrazeneca that deserve our support
in light of all that they're doing to
produce vaccines
protect us from the virus and help us to
move forward
you mentioned a short while ago india
the largest
uh producer of vaccines in the world
they are not going to be exporting
vaccines to us for at least
two to three months we're told surely
that is going to have some bearing on
our supply
well we've built an infrastructure in
this country which really is
world-class it would enable us to
vaccinate even more people than we have
done
in recent weeks millions more people and
so the more
vaccines we can secure the more jabs can
go into people's arms
but we do have enough supply
in sight to continue to meet our
obligations so that means that
if you have an appointment for your
second job you should not be worried
that will be honored you will get that
jab on the date that you were provided
and we will meet those two critical
targets as i said the 15th of april
for the over 50s plus the clinically
extremely vulnerable
and the rest of the population the adult
population
by the end of july and so we'll continue
to be one
if not the leading country in the world
for the vaccine
rollout but if we can secure more supply
and we're confident that we will do
incidentally uh in the months ahead then
we can continue to increase the pace
which is critical because the vaccine at
the end of the day is
our route out of this situation let's
move on to this
program to support vulnerable families
how is it going to factor in the the
pandemic you're
saying that 165 million pounds is going
to be
assigned to this well we've for many
years been working with
families through a program that's well
known called
troubled families and today we're
deciding to
recreate that program renew it and
refresh it in light of the pandemic and
it's going to be called uh supporting
families and it aims to bring together
all of the different agencies of
government
from schools local councils the nhs
gps to support families as a unit
and make sure that they have the wrap
around care and support that they need
to tackle many different challenges as
we come out of the pandemic
ensuring that fewer children go into
care that more children can stay in
school and thrive
as they go back to face-to-face teaching
that we look after people's health
including their mental health and we
help more people back into the workplace
i think this sort of program has never
been more important and so
it's right that we invest in it and
we're aiming to
directly support at least 69 000
families
this year uh potentially far more than
that
and ensure that those families get the
care the support and the guidance that
they need
to thrive in the months and years ahead
can i just ask you about the uh batley
grammar school and the incident there
what was the teacher right
to show a cartoon of the prophet
muhammad to children
well i i don't know precisely what the
teacher
did in the classroom we know that the
school is
looking into the matter and investigator
and that's absolutely right the
department for education
is liaising with the school and with the
local council
what i can say is that there has to be
an appropriate balance
we have to ensure that there is free
speech
that teachers can teach uninhibited but
that has to be done in a respectful and
tolerant way and that's
a balance that's to be struck by
teaching professionals
and by the schools concerned what i
would also
add is that i was disturbed to see
scenes of
people protesting outside the school
that is not right
we shouldn't have teachers members of
the staff of schools feeling intimidated
and the reports that
a teacher may even be in hiding is very
disturbing
that is not a road that we want to go
down in this country so i would strongly
urge people who are concerned about this
issue
not to do that robert jenner housing
secretary thank you very much for
speaking
to us this morning
still to come on the show as the nsbcc
reports more than half of online child
sex crimes are on facebook's platforms
i'll be asking a former government
advisor on online child safety
what can be done to tackle the issue
that's at 7 30.
at 7 45 we'll be finding out how we can
best help university students after a
year of disruption
and stress
what's the best way of ensuring
everybody gets the vaccine as
early as possible dr sarah schiffling
is an expert in vaccine supply and will
join me just after eight o'clock
chinese officials have imposed sanctions
on a number of british mps and
organizations in the uk it's in response
to sanctions introduced by britain
against individuals from china because
of concerns over human rights issues in
xinjiang
when our asia correspondent tom cheshire
joins me now from
beijing and tom um this has ratcheted up
the situation what's the likely response
to be from the uk
well i think china would frame this as a
retaliatory measure what's quite
interesting is this
is a response to uk sanctions the first
uk sanctions
imposed on chinese government officials
that was unveiled on monday and that
happened in concert with the eu with the
us with canada they all unveiled
sanctions at the same time
but i don't think china was necessarily
expecting the uk to
unveil those sanctions when the eu
applied its sanctions
china straight away applied sanctions to
uh members of the european parliament
other organizations in europe it's taken
a lot longer
for them to get around to the uk but
they have applied it now and they say
it's because of the these people
maliciously spreading lies and
disinformation it targets
mps in the uk including ian duncan smith
the former conservative leader but also
organizations
as you say including the china research
group a mainly conservative group of mps
focused on china and also essex court
chambers which is
a barrister's firm which put out a legal
opinion saying what's happening in
xinjiang in northwest china with the
uyghur people
could constitute genocide so this is
china really pushing back we've seen
that all week actually
both in terms of uh responding to those
eu sanctions but also
uh there's a boycott at the moment of uh
western clothing companies including h
m and nike uh it has been sort of spun
as an organic boycott spontaneous
boycott
it's got a lot of backing from state
media and these companies have pledged
not to use material from xinjiang
because of the allegations of forced
labor
in that region and as a result uh
chinese consumers are saying they won't
shop there they're getting a lot of air
time there and that looks like
a sort of concerted campaign here in
china to push back
against those sanctions against those
allegations of forced labor so this is
really china
doubling down it doesn't look like it's
going to change any of its behavior any
of its policies towards the uyghurs
uiga people in xinjiang this is them
drawing a line
both for individuals for governments for
politicians but also businesses
who try and cross that line tom thank
you
more than half of online child sex
crimes recorded by police in england and
wales took place on
facebook-owned platforms according to
the figures published by the nspcc
the charity says instagram is being used
most commonly
and as ashna hurinag reports the nspcc
is concerned cases could go unreported
if the company goes forward with its
plans for end-to-end
encryption frida was groomed online from
the age of 13 by a stranger
in his thirties we're not using her name
to protect her identity
their messages were constant and at
times dangerous
he was asking for more explicit content
from me and
we're having more explicit conversations
and everything
and at this point he wants to transition
over to whatsapp and i started sending
him
explicit photos because that was what he
wanted
the encryption of messaging services
allows every conversation to be private
and untraceable making it harder to
police child abuse
and grooming online it felt more intense
and intimate there and
i was less worried about the things i
was sending him getting elsewhere
the nspcc says the privacy it allows
risks fueling
child abuse last year police recorded
more than 9
400 instances where online communication
was being used to commit sexual
or indecent image offenses against
under-18s
52 took place on facebook-owned apps
with instagram the most used platform
accounting for a third of
all incidents the charity fears many of
these could go
unreported if end-to-end encryption is
expanded
across more platforms without safeguards
in place
what facebook wants to press ahead and
do is to
put a blindfold on itself it means that
abusers
really will be able to groom children to
be able to share child abuse images
safe in the knowledge that the chances
of that activity those criminal deeds
being detected
is very low indeed we have to see really
effective legislation that ensures that
children's safety is is not just a
voluntary consideration
a government spokesperson told us the
burden to protect children will fall
solely on social media companies
to prove they're doing all they can to
keep children safe
and they will not be able to use
encryption as an excuse
tech companies must put public safety at
the heart of their system designs
or face heavy fines we approached
facebook for comment but they have yet
to respond
for many children safety remains a
priority when so often
the danger they face in the modern world
is on the other end of a screen
ashna harinag sky news
time now for a look at the morning's
other main stories for you
and the stay local order will be lifted
in wales tomorrow meaning there'll be no
domestic travel restrictions
for the first time since it entered
lockdown on december the 20th
first minister mark drakeford has
confirmed people will also be able to
stay in self-contained
holiday accommodation police have
arrested two people in connection with
an
outbreak of covid19 at a care home in
devon
nine deaths have been reported at holmes
lee care home in
sidford in the last month which are all
believed to be coveted related
a fifty-seven-year-old woman from
sidmuth and a thirty-year-old man from
exeter
have been arrested on suspicion of
willful neglect
lorry drivers arriving in the uk could
be subject to mass
testing for coronavirus under new
government plans
according to a report in the daily
telegraph officials will announce this
weekend that those
previously exempted including hauliers
and border force officers
will have to take a test once they're in
britain rather than at the border
to avoid delays rishi sunak has called
on employers to
end working from home and allow staff
back in the office
or risk them defecting to rival
employers
the chancellor said working in an office
is crucial for young people to get to
know colleagues
and seek out mentors to help their
career
let's take a look now at the latest
coronavirus figures for the uk
6 397 new coveted 19 cases have been
reported with
63 more deaths across the uk
that takes the total number of people
who've died to 126
445. the figures also show that 28.99
million first doses of a vaccine have
now been given
it could take weeks to reopen the suez
canal as one of the world's largest
container ships remains beached across
the whole width of the waterway
salvage experts are trying to work out
how to free the ship the ever given
which is stacked high with cargo dozens
of ships are now queuing up behind
the marooned vessel the series canal
which provides a vital link between the
red sea
and the mediterranean carries more than
a tenth of all global trade
and has been a key artery for the world
economy for around 150 years
iva bennett reports a team of tugboats
was put to work on a stricken container
ship but despite the considerable power
of their combined engines
the ever-given didn't budge wedged
across the suez canal
the scale of the problem dwarfing the
machines that had been seen
as a solution the company trying to free
the ship
warned it could remain here for weeks
creating a nightmare scenario for global
trade
the traffic jam it's created is already
more than 150 ships long
among their cargo oil gas and grains one
of the world's busiest shipping lanes at
a standstill
this is the maritime equivalent of a
blocked coronary artery
a hiccup like this sort of sets everyone
back
everyone was already scrambling to get
back to normal
and serve what has been quite strong
demand for
traded goods and yeah no one needs
another delay on on top of everything
else and it does underline
just how important and how finely
balanced the whole system is
the british government said the incident
could cause delays for uk-bound
deliveries
while the japanese owner of the
quarter-mile long ship apologized for
the disruption
it was supposedly caused by the vessel
being blown off course
by a sudden strong wind and a dust storm
but experts say
that's nothing new these vessels are
built for that
and these vessels are capable of
handling them so it's
it while it that could have been one of
the major factors that contributed for
it it also depends on the skill level of
the huntsmen who's on the wheel even at
high tide the efforts to refloat the
ever given were futile
salvage experts and canal officials are
now considering removing containers to
make it
easier to shift but with up to 20 000 on
board
this is no quick fix either bennett sky
news
the ministry of defence says all hawk t1
planes the type of jet used by the red
hours have been grounded after a royal
navy jet crashed
in cornwall yesterday two pilots are
currently recovering in hospital
after ejecting before a crash landing my
reporter melinda vasilenovich joins me
now
at melinda festival tell us about the
the condition of the the pilot and
any subsequent investigation
well thankfully the pilots did not
receive any significant
injury and they are in stable condition
according to
the police we know they were initially
treated at the scene and then they were
airlifted to a hospital
in plymouth and the ministry of defence
says that they decided to ground this
type of aircraft as a precautionary
measure
while the investigations are ongoing and
while the pilots thankfully seem to be
okay the
ejection seat company manufacturer
said that this was the first time in 18
years that the royal
navy aircraft had to eject a seat so
they are taking
this seriously and of course this is the
same type of
aircraft the hawk t1 jet that the red
arrows
also use and they are really the public
face of the raf and one of the world's
premier
aerobatics display teams now they
normally start training in october and
they would be using
this time for valuable practice ahead of
their summer
display season however you know as as
everything with coronavirus that
timetable
has been appended and there's no set
events
as of yet for 2021 but certainly
the longer that this jet remains
grounded the more valuable time
they will lose in practice and the
ministry of defense has said that they
will continue
reviewing the situation uh and
evaluating it
as more information comes to light
lena thank you time now for a look
at the weather with the naz one out next
one in
what's it gonna look like today
a bit like that for today actually one
in one out
well first out will be a band of rain
sweeping south and eastwards
then coming in will be some showers some
of them wintry and it will be turning
colder as well
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning so we're entering a brief
cold spell now lasting about
24 hours or so and uh it will be turning
quite cold
in fact the showers that will be flowing
through with the cooler airflow will
also turn
increasingly wintry as well currently
though it's a fairly mild start to the
day we've got to
spells of rain across parts of central
southern and western scotland
spreading to northern western parts of
england wales it will continue spreading
its way south and eastwards
through uh today down towards parts of
the midlands central southern and
eastern england this afternoon therefore
it is becoming brighter as you can see
for many areas but we've already got
blustery showers across northern western
parts that are already turning wintry
over the high ground of scotland
and they will become more widespread
this afternoon across much of
ireland northern ireland scotland and
northern western parts of england and
well so as you can see turning
increasingly wintry now mostly across
the high ground
any sleet and snow showers but may even
be as far south as parts of
wales and then through the day it will
turn
more wintry across some low levels of
the north especially so
into tonight where there will be the
risk of ice as well across the northwest
and widespread for us too
the eu has warned astrazeneca it must
fulfill its contracts with europe
before sending vaccines elsewhere but
officials stopped short of immediately
introducing export restrictions
speaking to us earlier the housing
secretary robert generic said he was
confident the uk will hit all its
vaccine targets
and urged the eu to stick to its
commitments we will continue to
discuss the situation with the european
union to encourage
them to stick to the very clear
commitments that they gave
just a few weeks ago which were that
existing contractual obligations
will be honored that vaccines and other
medicines can cross borders
unhindered the more vaccines we can
secure the more jabs can go into
people's arms
but we do have enough supply
insight to continue to meet our
obligations so that means that
if you have an appointment for your
second job you should not be worried
that will be honored you will get that
jab on the date that you were provided
and we will meet those two critical
targets as i said the 15th of april
or the over 50s plus the clinically
extremely vulnerable
and the rest of the population the adult
population by the end of july
president biden has come under pressure
on migration during his first news
conference since moving into the white
house
there's been a surge of migrants since
his election which he insists is largely
down to the cooler conditions
in january and february mr biden also
used the news conference to set an
increased vaccine target
of delivering 200 million covet 19 jabs
in his first 100 days
our u.s correspondent cordelia lynch
reports
it took 64 days to get there and joe
biden tried to craft the opening
with a boost we will by my 100th day in
office
have administered 200 million shots
in people's arms that's right 200
million shots in
100 days i know it's ambitious
twice our original goal but no other
country in the world has even come
close not even close
to a perception he is a soft touch
i'd like to think it's because i'm a
nice guy but it's not it's because of
what's happened
every year let me say one other thing on
this if you take a look
at the number of people are coming
the vast majority the overwhelming
majority of people
coming to the border crossing are being
sent back
congratulations mr president
such is the curse of the washington
bubble he's already being asked if he'll
be back
in four years time have you decided
whether you are going to run for
re-election
in 2024 you haven't set up a re-election
campaign yet as your predecessor had by
this time
my predecessor need to need it to
my predecessor oh god i miss him
um no an answer is yes my plan is to run
for reelection that's my expectation
on foreign policy expectations he
painted a portrait of a complex
relationship
with china's leader xi jinping doesn't
have a democratic with a small d
bone in his body but he's a smart smart
guy
he's one of the guys like putin who
thinks that autocracy
is the wave of the future democracy
can't function in an ever com
an ever complex world but folks
i'm going thank you very very much i
appreciate it thank you
a quick exit for a man who wants to
limit his stage time
and deliver more than he promises
cordelia lynch sky
news washington
the university of southern california
has agreed to pay more than 1.1
billion dollars to patients treated by a
former campus gynecologist
accused of sexual abuse 74 year old
george
tyndall is to face trial after being
charged with sexually assaulting
21 female patients allegations he denies
it's the biggest sex abuse linked payout
in higher education history this will no
longer be tolerated
usc is not the only university that has
a dirty doctor
ucla has one we know that there was one
at johns hopkins
we know there was one at michigan state
larry nassar
this needs to change this is a
phenomenon of medicine
that needs to be exposed usc preferred
to spend
massive amounts of money on damage
control and on their fancy lawyers
and they really told us just to move on
they didn't want to reckon
with decades of senseless horror that
they had allowed to go on
with their knowledge
at least five people have been killed by
tornadoes sweeping across alabama
toppling trees and demolishing homes as
many as eight tornadoes have hit parts
of the deep south leaving more than
twenty 000 people
without power three of those killed were
members of the same family
people in gibraltar will be free to walk
around without a mask from
sunday as most of the population has now
been vaccinated
new coronavirus infections in the
british territory have plummeted
with none reported on wednesday a
nighttime curfew has now been lifted
allowing bars and restaurants to stay
open until 2
a.m
a british film about female grief and
vengeance is one of the front-runners
for this year's oscars
but the impact of promising young women
is likely to be felt for far longer than
the awards
season because it tackles the subject of
men's predatory behavior towards women
here's our entertainment reporter claire
gregory
i think you should go but a second ago
you were determined for me to stay
i'm a nice guy are you it's the story of
a woman avenging the rape of her best
friend
as well as being part of the awards
conversation with six bafta and five
oscar nominations
it's triggered a conversation that goes
much deeper an all too familiar tale of
predatory behavior
people feel very strongly about the
movie
just really quite simply the use of
alcohol
in um you know in inverted comma
seduction
because absolutely when i was growing up
it was completely
it was a joke it was it was a sort of
banter
to get girls drunk and take them home
women were kind of forced to
either be quiet about it or join in on
the joke because
because nobody would listen and nobody
else cared
it's disturbing because it is uh very
very
common what are you doing
in casting actors known for playing good
guys the film sends a message about
perception
versus reality raising questions over
societal attitudes and complicity
we've all grown up watching this story
told
through a different lens so i think it's
sort of understandable that we've
normalized it so much this is a film
that really does speak to everybody and
everybody's part in this
how did last night end the latest in a
number of dramas to examine abusive
behavior like michaela cole's i may
destroy you and billy piper's i hate
susie
the film treads the line between
entertainment and commentary while
tackling pertinent issues
this is coming out four years after the
meet hashtag me too reckoning
and it's a conversation that we
shouldn't let slide we need to keep it
going because actually
things haven't been changing for women
who have felt frustration
anger and i suppose this collective
grief
is something that they can relate to do
you still have feelings for andrew
director emerald fennell known for
writing killing eve and for her role in
the crown
has made history with this as one of two
women oscar nominated for best director
but her biggest success may be that this
contributes to a power shift in
hollywood
allowing more women to tell their own
stories who needs brains
they never did a girl any good claire
gregory sky news
returning now to one of our main stories
this morning as we've been reporting
new figures published by the nspcc
suggests that more than half of online
child sex crimes recorded by police in
england and wales
took place on facebook-owned platforms
with instagram
the most commonly used and i'm joined
now by the secretary of the uk
children's charities coalition on
internet safety john carr
who also used to advise the government
on the issue good morning to you
um what impact in your estimation
has uh social media and the internet had
on on the rate
of uh child sexual abuse
well it's it's completely transformed it
uh
i mean it's always been there
unfortunately it's always been a feature
of our society but
the arrival of the internet has um put
it on steroids so to speak um
and no you know the evidence of that is
is available here in nsbcc
statistics but this isn't the only piece
of evidence matt let me just say
because facebook is an american company
subject to american federal law
it has to report every single incidence
of
an illegal child sex abuse image or an
attempt to groom a child to the national
center for missing and exploited
children in
in washington dc and last year it
received
that center received 21.7 million
reports covering 35 million
uh videos of child sex abuse and
33 million still pictures and 93
of those were on facebook
so therefore what does facebook need to
do to stop this happening
well facebook is about to make it a
great deal worse
at the moment under because of the us
federal law
and because of the way facebook i'm glad
to say cooperate with the british police
they do make reports whenever they find
these materials which is why
nspcc can produce these numbers today
but what facebook is planning to do
is introduce what they call strong
encryption on the facebook messenger and
instagram direct platforms and what that
means
is all of these images will become
invisible
to facebook which means they won't be
able to find them
they won't be able to report them and so
these images of children being raped
will continue to be circulated
these instances of children being
groomed by paedophiles or bullied or
whatever it might be
will still happen and facebook won't be
able to see them and won't be able to do
anything about them
and has the case been been put to
facebook the nspcc
organizations like that has they put the
case to them that encryption will
actually
make it a more dangerous area for young
people
repeatedly and facebook acknowledge that
that's what will happen but what
facebook say
is that the market in inverted commerce
demands greater privacy
which is why they are introducing strong
encryption
they say they're going to do other
things to try and stop these things
happening before they get as it were
into
a messenger or into instagram uh direct
but the simple truth which they are not
denying is that once these images or
once these messages go into an
encrypted environment they will be
invisible
and there's nothing that the company can
do
to change that because that's just the
way encryption
works and frankly it is unacceptable and
we want the government to hurry up
and publish the online harms bill that's
been talking about for over three years
now
and in that bill it must create a very
explicit
legal obligation on all companies and
say
if you're going to use strong encryption
okay in principle we don't have
an issue with that but you must show us
that you're able to do it in a way that
guarantees children can be kept safe
so you're obviously not um persuaded by
the the company's assurances that they
they have other measures that can keep
children safe
absolutely not and one of the reasons
i'm not persuaded by the way is
and in a way let's be fair to facebook
we only know about these numbers because
they're being reported
in environment and that's they can only
be reported because these environments
are not currently encrypted
look at apple uh look at some other
companies
where their their services are already
encrypted
and the number of reports being received
from them are very close to zero
whatsapp uh which is actually also owned
by facebook but was already
encrypted i think last year there were
only something like 200 reports coming
out of whatsapp
and that's because facebook can't see
anything that's happening
on whatsapp now you know i'm in favor of
privacy don't get me wrong we need
privacy for banking for you know
security of nuclear reactors national
infrastructure there's no
issue in principle about the importance
of privacy
but if you introduce it in these mass
environments these
messaging environments where you've no
idea who the people are coming on
and you know that pedophiles and other
people who are interested in
exchanging illegal sexual content about
children if you know that they're there
why would you do it particularly is i
might say
why did why do people feel we need more
privacy it's we need more privacy
because of the behavior of companies
like
facebook so they create the problem and
then they come up with the wrong
solution
john car thank you very much for sharing
your insight on this
particular story and quite worrying
trends there thank you
rain will spread southeastwards this
afternoon over the midlands central
southern and eastern england
elsewhere we'll see blustery showers in
between sunny spells
turning increasingly wintry especially
over the high ground
it will be colder through the day as
well so taking a look at the air
pollution levels on a scale of 1 to 10
with 10 being very high
most places will remain at a low level
of 1 to 3 again but coastal parts of the
north and west of the uk and ireland
will see occasionally moderate levels
where it'll be windy
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
now what's the best way to help
university students after a year of
stress and disruption universities uk
which represents institutions across the
country
says the government must not take
students resilience
for granted the president of
universities uk professor julia
buckingham is also the vice chancellor
of brunel university in london joins me
now good morning to you and
what what's meant by that statement not
taking the resilience
of students for granted that the
government should not do that
well good morning festival students i
think have had a really
tough year this year um many of them
have been living at home
probably over a million of them living
at home studying online
um and in a very very isolated
environment and we're now in a position
where we have roughly 50 of our students
are back on campus because they are
doing
subjects which require practical um
practical work
but what i call the other 50 are still
at home
and universities uk is asking the
government
when it makes its decisions about
releasing the
lockdown restrictions that it considers
these students very very carefully
we are very concerned about their mental
health and well-being
and also about their personal
development and it's not a very
comfortable position to have
fifty percent of our students being in
this position and the other fifty
percent
on campus but how we're prepared are you
to uh welcome back the remainder of
these students to two campuses
universities are very very well prepared
to welcome students back we've invested
huge amounts of money and vast amounts
of time in making our campuses truly
covered safe so that we can teach
students in a face-to-face environment
and students can enjoy other activities
in a safe
face-to-face environment i want to
stress that there is
minimal evidence of transmission in
face-to-face learning environments
and the ons data so that infection rates
amongst staff in higher education are
very low
all of us have invested in asymptomatic
testing facilities
on campus so all of our students are
expected to be tested
twice a week and canvas infections are
very low
i can say in my own university at brunel
throughout the entire pandemic
the level of infections has been much
lower than it has been in the
surrounding environment
so i am really concerned as i said
earlier about students mental health and
well-being
i'm very concerned also about the
personal development of students
so much of which depends on those
face-to-face human
interactions i run a university where i
have a huge number of students from
underprivileged backgrounds
and i know only too well it is those
personal interactions
that help those students develop the
confidence and the other skills that
perhaps their more privileged peers have
already got and i want to be in a
position where i can really
help those students give them extra
coaching give them careers advice
and make sure i'm doing the very best i
can to ensure they have the best
outcomes
from their time at university uh you've
mentioned a couple of times your
concerns
about the mental health of your your
students uh what provisions are being
put in place
to help them in that respect and have
ongoing help
we have invested a lot in mental health
support so we've expanded our facilities
very very considerably
so we have more counsellors than we've
had before we've got more mental health
advisors than we've got before
and we've also we have a whole
university approach to mental health and
well-being
so all of our staff understand the
importance of
keeping a very very close eye on
students and of course it's much much
easier
to do that in a face-to-face environment
where you're with the students and you
see the students
than it is in a remote environment we
also of course work closely with the nhs
to make sure that students who need
medical help
can get that help as quickly as we can
possibly get it for them it's not always
easy
it can be very difficult but we
certainly um invest a huge amount in
trying to support mental health
it's one of the things i care about most
professor julia buckingham thank you
very much for speaking to us this
morning we've got some sound issues here
but we've finished the interview thank
you
just some breaking news to bring you now
foreign secretary dominic
raab has issued a statement following
sanctions imposed by
china on more than a dozen uk
individuals and organizations including
tory mps he says it speaks volumes
that while the uk joins the
international community
in sanctioning those responsible for
human rights abuses
the chinese government sanctions its
critics
if beijing want to credibly rebut claims
of human rights abuses
in zhenjiang it should allow the un high
commissioner
for human rights full access to verify
the truth so the foreign secretary
they're
saying that there should be full access
to verify
the truth time now to take a look at the
weather for you with nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
a very good morning to you so we're
heading into a brief cold spell over the
next 24 hours or so with increasingly
wintry
showers about as well but to begin with
this morning it's mild across most
places
but there are already wintry showers
developing and some snow
across parts of scotland mainly over the
high ground there but there's also
a mixture of rain sleet and snow showers
across parts of ireland and northern
ireland again the wintry outbreaks
mostly across the high ground over these
areas meanwhile there's
rain across much of scotland over parts
of the north and west of england and
wales some showers further south and
east and that band of rain
will be clearing for much of scotland
the north and west of england and
wales by midday heading across the
midlands central southern eastern
england this afternoon behind that it
gets
colder with increasingly wintry showers
mostly across the high ground but to
some
low levels of the north later